[Music]
subject for today
[Music]
can anyone uh tweet me at s crowder is
this is this the apple mouse pad
waterproof
i sure hope so doing a test we have
gerald a in with us today
yeah but more importantly we have gerald
b and because lawyer is not here
to lean what do you say hey hold on can
you do your do your impression of a
lamprey
[Laughter]
every time it gets me every time it's
uncanny he's good
a big river monsters fan uh quarterblack
is here
uh audio wade is here we have a lot to
get to today uh we are going to be
talking about kamala harris
uh and just the rape the rape that
surrounds her all the time
she's called by narefa went after
kavanaugh but now she was inspired by
jacob blake also alleged rapist violated
a restraining order
and she's like she's like a pig pen with
a cloud of rape
[ __ ] just follows her wherever she goes
so we'll point out some of those
inconsistencies
chris cuomo is a compulsive liar and i
will prove that there will be a ten
thousand dollar bet in addition to our
fight coming up on october third
don't listen the new vaccine may be out
come election time which we'll get to in
a second
impossible as well as the economic
recovery democrats senior obama
economists officials have told you
that they deserve to lose and uh i will
uh
i'll make my case we agree i'll make my
case
uh what's the question of the day i
guess the question is uh do you think
that jacob blake do you think it's gonna
be a me too movement
with this guy do you think that
eventually i mean this is a guy who was
alleged you know
rape and then violated the restraining
order right obviously
he was there was an active warrant out
currently for the sexual assault right
so it's not like
what bygones be buying on the warrant
you still haven't come in
to face the music for your your rapey
schemes
actually actively trying to find you
yeah they're actually violating the
restraining order and we say women are
afraid
i'm almost convinced now that that uh
the left they want
rape victims female victims silent
because they praise women who never come
forward never report it to the cops like
christine blasey ford and the fbi is
like i don't know what you want me to do
with this no
this is true uh versus women who go to
the cops go through the process woman of
color by the way with jacob blake
goes to the police hey this is what
happened gets an active warrant gets a
restraining order
calls them when he shows up again with a
knife to steal the keys and put the
children in the car
and the left doesn't care about her yeah
who knew all that harvey weinstein had
to do was go out and assault police
officers and get shot by them
rightfully so and then he would be fine
because apparently that cancels out the
rapey part that sounds more like a
bruckheimer
move uh let's see what cnn is talking
about right now
hey nearly 12 000 florida residents have
died from covet 19.
earlier this morning someone was on cnn
saying but by the way today of course uh
the death toll has reached a record high
well that's any death toll
right that's the death toll of humanity
the death toll of the flu if you never
end
like the because and the reason that it
tricks people is because we're used to a
flu season
right right going through which now
they're warning about is coming back up
again what do we have a flu isn't that
no
there was no actual flu but they just
keep it going they keep the never ending
tally it's like more uh
toaster deaths have reached all-time
highs today
more than yesterday that's because of
lyle we told him not to stick the butter
knife in the toaster to grab his
pop-tart but you know what he rolled the
dice
it's on him it's too bad all right uh
really quickly first let's go by the way
we do have these hats
villains hats one size fits all my ass
you see this oh wow
cause i have a famous guy head so it
just you dude
but not my not this dome um
let's go really quick i want to talk
about this because just i can't
the winning it's just it's uh it's two
months please
there's good reason to believe that we
may have uh
a vaccine or at least it may be approved
before election so it almost seems like
uh
well here is uh your president
nostradamus
so we're going to have a vaccine very
soon maybe even before a very special
date you know what data i'm talking
about
[Laughter]
off the prompter yeah you guys know and
you and
you eat it i love it i love it
and then of course uh the medium octane
but let's go specifically to uh first
pos candidate ever um
uh what she said about a trump vaccine
let's just say there's a vaccine
that is approved and even distributed
before the election
would you get it well i think that's
going to be an issue
buttercup um i will say is undertale
i would not trust donald trump
that is her tale that's how you know
when kamala harris they threw her a
curveball which is very rare is she
starts looking more like jabba the hutt
yeah
she goes well donald trump and they cut
back to whoever that was uh dana bash
and then it cuts back to
kamala harris and she's here and then it
cuts the database and cuts back and
she's gone
[Laughter]
when she acts like donald trump is in
some lab with beaker
and by the way don't light magnesium on
fire tread put it out with water it
doesn't work
ah makes it worse he knows his stuff he
knows
the elemental okay frankly table
it's more like a chart so he said we may
have it by i mean let's all guess
and he gave him himself enough wiggle
room i think because
they came out and said wait hold on we
don't have this by election you say i
admit
christmas
of our lord and savior jesus christ
ever heard of him very special it's a
very special day yes
and every single story that came out was
that he was rushing it yeah they were
saying there's no way
all of these experts by the way when
they say experts they just mean fouchy
at this point
it's like experts oh [ __ ] you well how
about dr brooks yeah get it no no
no how about johns hopkins no
this expert i got no strings to hold me
right now
uh so here's the media mocking him
mercilessly when he made that statement
on labor day he held another
campaign-style news conference at the
white house
teasing a coronavirus vaccine by
election day would you campaign style
experts will tell you cannot happen even
as he continues to suggest
without any evidence that a vaccine
could be ready by election day
there's almost like the president
sometimes has an inside track
it's like he has more information than
the average person and you can see it
when he says that that's when he gets
all kind of coy about it like
on a very sp on a very special day you
know what i'm talking about
right maybe ask your wife or his mom
little richie knows what i'm talking
about healing
um what kind of what kind of healing do
you think it is
i think you know but now they mocked
them mercilessly there's no basis for it
well i don't know if this counts as an
expert but here's the ceo of
pfizer dr fauci said it's unlikely
although possible
that you could know about efficacy and
safety
so where does this stand for you for our
vaccines our
phase 3 is progressing very well we have
already recruited 25 000.
25 000. when the calculator
depends on multiple uh variables but
right now
we our model our base case predicts that
we will
have an answer in by the end of october
okay i know
yeah by the end of october but i want a
uh token owen to bring up
valladolo from the young pope that's who
he reminds me of
he reminds me of by yellow he's so
cunning and scheming
but right now it says october oh october
october
it's weird
unless you mail in your ballot really
early it's even sooner than i bet you
thought i was saying election
or maybe halloween no canadian
thanksgiving
it's so soon the winning so special well
and not only did he say he was rushing
it they said that they were saying that
the fda wasn't doing their jobs hold us
i can bring up by vallejo do we have
vayello
we have my va yellow you just said we
had it and now we don't have it he
pulled it up
he pulled it up
who by the way is not to be trusted
unlike the expert who hasn't seen a
patient or invented anything in the
private sector his
entire life you were saying something
yeah they were saying that the fda
fda was acting improperly under pressure
from the administration there's no way
that this can happen
and then i love it cnn led with the
story this morning and said now
obviously in response to the fda being
rushed in this administration's claim
they come out and said we won't release
a vaccine until it's safe
nine companies sign this including
pfizer and then right after that
pfizer's like
yeah the timeline looks about right yeah
we're gonna get that man looks about
right
are you kidding me and by the way don't
you just love how it switched to people
like are you anti-science you're
anti-vaccine if there's not a vaccine
available i'm like hey you know what
trump did fast track it and put it in
operation warp speed now the fire ceo
i don't trust big pharma the way i'm
putting that in my body who would be
more of an expert
at developing a new novel pharmaceutical
than the pharmaceutical industry
you're going to take your chances with
echinacea you silly [ __ ]
trust the experts what about stupid do
the experts not include those who are
actually piloting actually innovating
and creating new drugs and treatments by
the way
that's all it almost entirely comes from
the united states and the private sector
it doesn't come from government
healthcare you can see the research in
my homeland of canada where i was uh
where i was raised how the research just
was cut in about half immediately when i
went to socialize healthcare the world
benefits
from our private sector research it
doesn't mean they always get it right
but
everyone right now is is just holding
out hope
that these big pharma executives the
people we hate are going to come in and
save them unless of course they do it on
donald trump's timeline
in which case we will shun the vaccines
too
which by the way that turns it into an
aerosol and it changes the chemical
reaction and it's no longer safe
the left goes anti-vax hope you have
your n95 masks
i'm hoarding them because that's my game
plan uh
right now let's see what they're saying
at cnn before we continue
um everything since the ted offensive
trump launches on youtube launches
unprecedented attack on military leaders
he appointed okay
we have some things to move on to but
but people are can i say one thing on
that real quick
remember the military industrial complex
that the democrats said was
only in it to make money and kind of
like yeah they hate it until now
now donald trump goes after them they're
like how dare you go after the military
how dare you go after crazy the troops
that you've denigrated and insulted for
so
long and hey can i get where's code pink
i don't know sooner or later they're
going to show up and show their tits
it's in the contract it's real yeah it's
crazy right now
it's just unbelievable trust the experts
donald trump goes with it we go with the
expert big pharma okay well now they
they're not to be treated we think
fauci's going to create
a vaccine and by the way i didn't want
to give any air time to this story that
was going out
uh right now did he call anyone losers
and so you know why i don't want to give
it air time because it's been refuted by
more than 10 sources including john
polten as well as emails call logs and
you can run a simple search to see if
the weather checked out
it's untrue it's entirely based on
conjecture just like
every single leftist conspiracy they
talk about conspiracy theories
brett kavanaugh being a gang rapist uh
russian collusion peeing with russian
prostitutes this idea that he
he hates by the everyone knew it was
untrue it was like cartoonishly evil
and yeah cnn wrestling mexicans dance on
their flat jig
look marine
like he's turning around with a cat an
inspector gadget for crying out loud
anyone bought this yeah and i love the
video of john bolton like the guy that
hates trump that just released a book
that would have put it in his book
because it would have sold more copies
if it were true
right no i was there and uh no never
heard him say any of that wow
crazy he would only benefit we have to
move on here but by the way first uh
please do consider joining mud club at
loudoun.com we will take your live chat
and that's my instagram right there
that's also available you can follow me
on instagram where there's a bunch of
stuff that
you don't see on the show namely my rule
is no
uh we'll nipples doing some live chat
with you a little later on you just lost
a bunch of followers
we have a story some stories to move on
to but i do want many of you have heard
this story
or read about the story of uh i mean
it's better we were just talking about
christmas this is better than chris
better yeah
okay after watching the initial clip i
think many of us felt born a new where
the guy threw the anta member through a
molotov cocktail and lit himself on fire
right and that's what he couldn't
breathe for at least two hours in and of
itself is funny enough
but uh we now actually have there's
there have been additional angles
released and we now have an exclusive
from another angle of
the antifa rioter throwing a molotov
cocktail and then trying to goose step
it off
[Music]
[Music]
oh
i think i figured this out myself if i
jump around like an arabian horse
high knees high knees high knees get
them up oh man
they're all just like punch and
pummeling yeah you know who came in and
saved the day by the way
police officers came in and put it out
oh they're so
man let it burn yeah they shot it out no
that's what they did they used their
firearms and they shot the fire out yeah
they shut the fire out
i would just be like all right well
listen
sorry this is sorry about your kicks bro
and this is why i appreciate our
officers because they have the kind of
restraint that we don't have because if
i were that officer
i would let it burn till that guy ended
up like we were soldiers down in my life
cocktail sorry sorry sorry you can't put
an ethanol flame out by doing a river
dance
no tap dancer for you oh my gosh it's
like those guys that light the flag on
fire and light themselves on fire it's
like ah it's all
it just feels like justice but you know
something it always feels like justice
uh you know what we know but
we'll get to our sponsor tomorrow i just
really don't give us enough
let's get to the uh this is what they
don't want to talk about let's go to cnn
really quickly why are they talking
about
nothing but conjecture by the way donald
trump just said people in the military
like me i think some people officials at
the pentagon don't like me so much
that's what he said which is totally
it's that's exactly
true sanders has said i support our
troops but i don't support the military
industrial complex only he doesn't know
what it is
if you ask about the right you ask
bernie about the military industrial
complex he'd try and find it on a map
well who does what johnson
the boot i know that what are you
are you senile all of a sudden yes
you seen joe biden he constantly
he poops unsubstantiated claims stephen
yes that's the legend allegedly
they're talking about something that's
complete conjecture and it must really
suck to have to base all of your
arguments on conjecture
and and we're going to be talking about
chris cuomo later but
in reference speaking of brian stelton
let's check out gerald b what do you
have to say
he stays in character with the lamp you
need to get a new gerald b
yeah no no i think that's about right
for gerald b
so they're not talking about the
economic recovery no
and this is something that no one else
has pointed out but to me is remarkable
and i want to make sure that i quote
this and get it right for you
um this is a politico story from may
okay so
this is why i think that donald trump is
going to
win in a landslide if the left continues
with kovid and the riots
and now they're clearly trying to
distance themselves from the riots but
it's almost as though that's worse
because people were going wait wait
but you donate it to the rioters yeah
you set them free
so this is from politico in may now
jason furman
he was a top economist under uh
president obama and he's a professor
at harvard okay so this was him talking
about the re-election again in may
if trump has any ability to do nuance he
would say
we are not there yet re-elect me to
finish the job the biden argument will
be the unemployment rate is still 12
and even with those millions of jobs we
are still down 15 million jobs and the
only way for this to be fixed
is new economic policy so he was saying
worst case scenario that even if donald
trump gets unemployment down to 12
we'll still try and show how when it was
up toward 20 how many jobs are still
lost well now this comes out so
may august september from cnbc
non-farm payrolls increased by 1.37
million
and it brought the unemployment rate to
8.4
so donald trump should win because the
democrats tell you that he should win
by they're just running promo for us now
it's over i think i'm going to win the
election
why's that uh i don't know ask obama
run clip absolutely i love that their
argument is
we're going to shut down the economy
it's going to create unemployment and
because there's unemployment he's a bad
president and needs to be taken out of
office and
he's still kicking their butt well in
their worst case scenario 12
it's on it's on track to be half that
right yeah it's on track to be
half that half half
half are you out of your trees sir why
would they live like i'm amazed
that they were so this i just they were
so misguided that they could be so
obtuse to actually list a number out
there that we blew
past only a month later like i mean come
on just try and like give yourself some
wiggle room
right the w's
they thought a 12 unemployment was too
ambitious so they thought they had a
meeting and said we're safe right we say
twelve four twenty down to twelve maybe
maybe sixteen but twelve so we'll even
we'll steal man
in here that's the opposite of strong
manning i'm working for the obama wine
house
uh well steel man them and say twelve
and then they're sitting there watching
it go down
like rooney's computer with absentee
days
exactly where the number's going and i
think they honestly felt like there was
going to be enough public fear and panic
because you know cnn is constantly
telling you to be afraid that
the economy wouldn't recover and that
they were going to be safe and that
their plan would work and i don't say
that to say that like this this
nefarious plot there might be
it is definitely in their interest when
you have people like john oliver saying
that they should have these kinds of
things happen so that it
wasn't john oliver was the other guy the
other guy from hbo came bill maher
he said it would be great for them too
economic downturn i know sorry
an economic downturn so that the
presidency would look like he is
terrible right right and even now they
can't do it they can't even get close
they can't do it there's no doubt that
the fundamentals of the economy are
unbelievable they're not good when the
economy is good and they suck when it's
bad they got it either way
there's you really it's like pick a lane
yeah there's all around
pick a lane and by the way at the end of
either lane it's a concrete girder oh
so and we've removed your parking brake
and we've stepped the brake lines
no air bags have fun we paint a tunnel
on the side they sniff their own brake
lines really
yeah what is this looney tunes yeah this
is why i think
uh also donald trump is going to win
because people have said this before too
so now we have the economy worst case
scenario they thought would be 12
unemployment and that's also really sad
the fact that democrats their worst case
scenario is a lower unemployment
they are backing right now on violent
unrest more violent unrest so they can
blame that on trump and higher
unemployment so they can blame that on
trump
again like i said democrats are the
party of negativity
the only way a republican gets elected
is if there's hope is if there's
optimism because
if republicans are the party of the rich
let's just say that the party of the
middle class upper middle class like 80
something percent of americans who
benefited from the tax cuts this company
hired two new people
let's just say that they aren't at the
bottom
absolute scraping the welfare barrel of
society
right anyone who's benefited from donald
trump or at least you want to be in
those categories
you have to vote for donald trump
because they're saying this is the
possibility and it's benefited those
people we believe that you can do the
best for yourself we believe that you
can pull yourself up by your bootstraps
we believe that if we get out of the way
you can be successful and we see that
with record high wage growth that we've
ever seen in modern american history the
democrats say
listen if you don't vote for us it's
broken it's lost you're going to see
more violence you're going to see more
unemployment donald trump to win
re-election wants unemployment as low as
possible
and wants as little violence as possible
he needs that to be reelected democrats
require highest unemployment they can
possibly create
and the highest violent unrest they can
possibly imagine that is what
that's what's required for either party
to win this right now and the polls
reflect that okay so let's be clear
here's something else a lot of people
have been saying
well with donald trump you know they
didn't account for the secret voters the
last election
right yeah right they didn't account for
it and now they they weigh the sk first
off i haven't seen polls really weighing
it for that
and i would wager that considering
people are getting
shot in the right yeah and people are
losing their jobs
i would wager that you have more secret
trump voters at this point
yeah and statistically i have something
to back that up the latest investors uh
investor business daily the ibd
tip ibd inflammatory bowel disease just
the tip paul
shows that 20 of voters
are uncomfortable revealing their
political uh candidate preference
and that number's up to 28 for
independence now
let me ask you to think about this for a
second twenty percent of americans
are uncomfortable twenty eight percent
of independence right when we talk about
the undecided vote uncomfortable listing
their political candidate preference
do you think that people would be afraid
right now
to list their favoritism to express it
publicly for mr
empathy dementia himself joe biden or
listing their preference
for the president who if they merely put
up a bumper sticker their car is getting
keyed or a sign it's getting burned down
and if they express their support
publicly they get fired from their job
who do you think again this is 20 of
voters don't want to list it 28 percent
of independence why am i moving my hands
like donald trump i've been doing the
character too much
who do you think the majority hey the
vast majority of those people are
actually supporting
you think it's the biden people who are
afraid well let's let's just compare
that
if you are a biden supporter right now
in hollywood in media
in the entertainment industry at all in
education we just saw a principal
rioting with black lives matter if you
support biden
it can only help your career prospects
if you sing it from the rooftops
if you are a donald trump supporter you
keep your head down and you surprise
people in the voting booth because you
don't want your lawn being burned down
right so this is 20 of people 28 of
independence
yeah and already the polls are
tightening big time so this is something
to me and keep in mind
joe biden let's be clear about this it
was a threat when he said do you really
think if you elect donald trump the
violence is going to stop right exactly
he's telling us
the violence will continue harris said
the same thing yeah it's an ultimatum i
don't know
what's gonna happen with the violence i
don't know it depends on who you elect
maybe they're coming for your suburbs
i don't know well all right i'm not
sending them or anything i hoped right
so
excuse me at the conventions they said
that the dnc put out a great platform i
have no idea what it is other than
raising taxes on
everybody right even though they say
it's just the rich it's everybody and
they said the rnc didn't get anything
exactly that too right meeting rapists
like kamala harris we'll get to that in
a second
jacob blake rapist they said the rnc
this is the first time they haven't put
out
a platform and i was like all you need
to say is i'm going to do what i was
doing before the world
almost ended and it was working really
really well the the democrats are
dependent on chaos they have nothing
else to sell they're dependent on chaos
and saying look the world's on fire
we can come in at least put out part of
it right donald trump is like the
world's on fire and i put it out
right look at the unemployment rate it's
going back look at the stock market
it's doing really well look at all of
these and you know it's wonderful tricks
he
largely put it out and i'm against some
of the big spending of course that we
see from donald
trump but i also understand there's a
little there is nuance there because
businesses were shut down by the
government
but he mostly put out the fire by
getting out of the way and helping
americans get back to work
he put out the fire he helped the
american economy by reducing taxes and
businesses and some people gave me crap
for my tweets
i know for a fact that we hired two
people because the business they go you
wouldn't do that
uh if you it's anecdotal but i'm using
an anecdotal example because it's
personal okay
because the statistics that are
reflected i can tell you exactly where
they are bryce and angela
yeah bryce and angela your jobs are a
direct result
of donald trump's tax policy and not
only because the money that we saved in
taxes which for many businesses are many
many tens of thousands of dollars
but also people don't understand there
are a lot of small businesses out there
that have to borrow money just to make
inventory for the next quarter they're
on credit just so they can stay afloat
and so when businesses
see that not only do they have less in a
in the form of a bill right now as far
as taxes at the end of their quarter but
they can see how it's going to
dramatically increase their profits over
the next year or two years guess what
they do
they invest r d and employees we've done
that right here
and if you join up at mug club light of
credit.com club listen you guys are the
ones who fund us will support
this movement everything we can do by
hiring more people we don't have any al
jazeera money it's funny i just thought
chank wigger going after daley wire or
sorry uh
prageru because they like billionaires
and they do it's a non-profit they have
billionaire funders whatever it is like
people who give money which is their
right to do
but it's funny to me that they're
talking about people being beholden to
investors
you have money from a terrorist foreign
entity
like what are you talking about don't
look back there all right
let's move on look money is money steven
all right
[Laughter]
go to an indian restaurant and they have
that stuff on a loop you're like oh this
is this is their top 40.
please kill me number one number two
alternative okay
i'm sure they say the same thing about
it i'm sure they do
yes that ferg is kind of gross
i know i get it listen that's one for
you india
um here's the latest kamala hair so
she's really proud of
jacob blake she met with him in the
hospital
and it's in a moving moment jacob senior
told senator harris that he was proud of
her
and the senator told jacob she was also
proud of him and how he is working
through his
pain um okay so let's get to it maybe
she was inspired first in case you don't
know jacob blake released a uh video
here um alleged rapist and violator
restraining order active warrant want to
be really clear because
we should care about the actual victims
like the woman who he sexually assaulted
allegedly and the police were trying to
protect she went through all of these
systems in place to actually protect
herself from rape legally
uh but maybe kamala harris was inspired
by this little number
please i'm telling you change our lives
out there we can stick together
make some money make make everything
easier for our people out here man
because there's so much time that has
been wasted
a couple of a couple of things there um
i guess if you include in wasted time
rape yes i would say that's not best use
of
you don't know it was rape it was only
rape in the third degree
was it digit right or was it underage i
don't know
i don't know i ain't telling this sounds
like a waste of time and talking about
money money isn't our primary concern
with your situation
jacob blake it's more so did you have a
weapon did you threaten the officers and
why were you again at your rape victim's
house alleged rape victim's house after
a restraining order and a warrant was
out for your arrest yeah is that the
hide your kids guy
it looks a lot like him and then he says
for we can make it better for our people
can you imagine if someone was white can
you imagine if that cop said hey listen
man
i'm just out here this was a guy i was
trying to protect this woman this
neighborhood because she called us there
was a restraining order she had been
sexually assaulted by this guy before
i'm trying to do my job for this
community and just make this world a
better place for our people
proud boys slash white private wait
supremacy alert
they tie them together no
i have no problem with him saying my
people by the way i don't it's just the
double standard well and i so i had a
little bit of hope when i saw this just
a little bit i know that i'm kind of
swimming against the stream here
i was hopeful yeah exactly i i know
one first and foremost he didn't take
any personal responsibility for his
actions
which is that's the line that's the goal
for us to get to first before anything
else if you committed sexual assault you
need
you should lead with at least eight
do you have anything to say about what
you did yeah exactly
coming out of his room for rape and hey
did you think about what you did
[Music]
we've all got a little work today maybe
we should make some money are you gonna
hey
this is perfect are you gonna stop
raping
hey hey look at me are you gonna stop
raping
there's an active warrant and
restraining order what do you say
i'm sorry what was that i'm sorry are
you gonna rape again
right exactly and so here you said
something before the show he's going to
speak again he's going to clarify some
of the things that he said i was hopeful
because i'm looking for positive stuff
sometimes right
and in this case i was hopeful because
he said there's too much life to live
i i've look what i've lost we've got a
chain and he says what we just showed
you've got to change the way you live no
no no no no no i know he didn't say it
like that though
seriously i'm hoping i'm really hoping
i'm hoping too that he's looking back
and going
i i did a lot of terrible stuff and it
put me in this place yeah and you guys
that are out there right now
stop what you're doing change your life
there's too much life to live god make
money go out and have a good life i hope
that's what he was saying
like the gang i'm just the gang land
ebenezer scrooge well pretty much
pretty much but here's the other thing
he assaulted the police officers we
forgot to mention that
i i must marry as a latin king here go
buy some fried chicken go and the police
did it all in one night of course they
can
of course they can bang bang exactly i
hope i hope that's what he meant but uh
we'll have he's declared lead with
apology for rape
i know i know i agree i agree yeah well
he's talking like a horoscope where we
can all only read our own positive
feelings onto it but really
you know he's trying to obscure the fact
that he and he's a bad guy yeah
he doesn't he doesn't deserve to be
lecturing people about how they should
live maybe
what do you mean maybe maybe he's a bad
guy no you said he was converting
oh but to me here's the thing regardless
of not saying this guy
uh deserves or ever deserves the death
penalty let me be really clear there's a
difference between forfeiting your right
to live and deserving
capital punishment and there are
offenses that are deserving of that
i would argue that rape should be but
that's not a part of our judicial system
right now
right so this man did forfeit his right
to live when he
allegedly sexually assaulted a woman at
the very least it was enough of a
situation where the woman
rightfully went to police filed a report
got a restraining order there was a
warrant
she called him again when he was there
and he was fighting and taking the keys
and said that he had a knife
and then he told the officers he had a
knife reached for a knife in his
floorboard while they were there to
protect again
the current rape victim yeah you forfeit
your right to live with that
she could have shot him and been
justified oh yeah yeah absolutely he
basically broke into the house and
started sexually assaulting her it's a
problem and by the way that happens all
the time
almost three million defensive uses of
firearms that you just don't hear about
and usually they're not even used
the guy comes in with his knife to the
rape victim's home and she shows him a
gun and he walks on his merry way and
the cops arrest him
right but i do think that that qualifies
this person as a bad guy
i know people are grey people are both
good and bad
but that does need to be addressed
especially when kamala harrison by the
way hit the notification bell
uh if you are on youtube we do this show
every morning at 10
a.m eastern um and uh of course at mug
club we do an entire another
35 45 minutes like today talking about
chris cole being a compulsive liar yeah
yeah
i'm excited about it's gonna be a fun
conversation kamala harris was inspired
by this
right and keep in mind did it just skirt
did it just
just somehow she forgot about
the multiple violent charges including
sexual assault keep in mind that this is
a woman
who tried to preclude brett kavanaugh
yeah
for being a member of the supreme court
uh from being a member of the supreme
court based on
completely baseless gang rape
accusations let's let's recall this
so i'm going to ask you one last time
are you willing to ask the white house
to authorize the fbi to investigate the
claims that have been made against you
well i'll do whatever the committee
wants of course
and i've heard you say that but a
witness i've not heard you answer a very
specific question that's been asked
which is are you willing to ask the
white house
to conduct an investigation by the fbi
to get to whatever you do they mean a
second investigation it's got to be the
second questions that have been done
the fbi would gather witness statements
you have to witness
i don't want to debate with you how they
do their business i don't want to debate
i want to talk about any of this on
faceless accusations
and questions as to whether there's any
basis for accusations because
you know what if you get with a pig in
the mud you both get dirty what dollar
dollar bills yo
i smoke weed once i think she's being
perfectly consistent i think she's just
lying all the time
she's saying an fbi she must mean a
second fbi investigation yeah right
right right with brett kavanaugh she
wanted to ruin this man's life really
would have ruined this man's life if he
didn't fight back which is why you don't
lay down for the left anymore at all
there is no
there is no possibility of being neutral
uh and she goes would you allow an
investigation well do you they would go
through
witness testimony witnessed it do you
have any of those no the fbi even after
they tried to conduct
some kind of investigation i don't know
what happened a second ago because they
were demanded to do another one they
said listen listen okay
there are these baseless accusations
that have come out several of these
women have completely recanted they've
pulled it back and the ones from
christine blasey ford
don't make any sense she said that she
was at a party where no one else they've
only said that that party didn't happen
and she described a house that we know
doesn't exist with an eight-block radius
and then she described an entirely
different house how do you want us to
run an investigation and kamala harris
goes we should
not allow this man to be in the supreme
court until we know more
there was enough evidence to actually
have an active warrant out for your
sexual assault
you inspire me it's inspiring exactly
he's a regular maya angelou get that out
of there stop
right and what about that what about the
time that she said she believed all of
joe biden's accusers
effectively calling joe biden a rapist
but that was in the primaries
that was a long time ago we don't have
to go back to that she really has had a
i mean there's just a lot there's so
much rape there there really is as far
as a scandal
she's like mr magu and that everyone
around her gets raped
and people like ah there's so much rapes
i can be vice president no you're not a
rapist at all i don't believe them
anymore
not a single one you're a good guy joe i
just don't listen just be consistent do
i think do i
we didn't really touch on the joe biden
rating a ton because it's saying again
it's another
accusation it was more credible than the
brett kavanaugh situation who is more
credibility than the donald trump
situation
and it's not even comparable if you look
at the jacob lake situation no no it's
not even close or the guys who were shot
in kenosha who by the way
had sexually assaulted minors those
people were actually convicted
so for some reason this this idea
of conjecture this idea of really sort
of exam
well i don't know did this person commit
someone has come forward if there's no
evidence
we should err on the side of caution and
destroy their livelihoods destroy their
careers
destroy their ability to be in the
public eye or really work in the private
sector at all
but if someone is actively charged or
convicted with rape
just ignore it as long as they're on the
right side yeah exactly and releasing a
video making a statement any any penance
that somebody does
does not change their past behaviors it
doesn't it doesn't have any impact on
what they did
and everybody in the media that is
putting this guy up as some kind of hero
or some kind of martyr for the cause
is just actively overlooking all of not
i don't even care if he was a rapist he
was fighting
police officers trying to go get a knife
that's all you need to know about this
case to know it's wrong
plus the million other things that we
know about this guy but i also think if
black lives matter not only obviously we
just had record uh deaths in chicago
this last weekend i mean again
technically it's always record i don't
mean to
tell you i mean yeah just a weekend
count yes i'm talking about a sprint an
interval if you will it was a long
weekend so
it was that monday people have been
really pissed off on mondays people have
some beers they got a lot of skewers and
labor
a case of the mondays um i don't
remember what i was about to say
something you guys keep thinking about
doesn't matter oh yeah we care about not
only the deaths that are going on in
these cities but also the rapes
right their record i women are obviously
women of color
are disproportionately raped by members
of people
by other black men in their community
and so are white women by the way
and now they don't reflect these uh
statistics in the uh the doj or the fbi
depending which years you go i don't
know if it's a doj or fbi we have a few
different crime statistics now they
don't categorize
uh race with the rapes and sexual
assault crimes
women are far more at risk this woman
was at risk this woman
called the cops and by the way that's a
beautiful thing that was a i don't want
to say a pleasant interaction
but that was an interaction that was
fruitful with the police
yeah she obviously felt scared and
sometimes people said that
women feel ashamed which you should not
if you are the victim of sexual assault
i want to be really clear
when i say that lena dunham is full of
it because she said that she regretted
the sex later on the next day
that's not the same as the victim of
jacob blake who actively went to the
police because she was violently
sexually assaulted you should have no
shame it doesn't matter what you were
wearing
doesn't matter what you said if a man
violently sexually assaults you have i
made that clear because you want to say
i'm a rape apologist kamala
the police sat down took a statement
they deemed that there was enough
evidence there to charge him and put an
active warrant out for jacob flake's
arrest
they said let us know if anything
happens here's a restraining order
he violated it going into her house
violently uninvited and she
called the police again this is a good
thing this should show you
how if we're talking about reforming
police we should look at that as a
microcosm go on a second a woman of
color
and some white and i don't know if they
were all white police officers
sat had a meeting and they tried to
bring a violent rapist to justice and
they had an incredible response time
when she called them again
this shows that not all cops are racist
and they do want to protect the most
vulnerable among us
namely rape victims female rape victims
of color instead
we completely ignore it to deify the
alleged rapist and man who assaulted
police officers
now that doesn't mean that he deserves
to die but in this case it's so
clear show me one by the way show me one
when people talk about these black lives
let's go through it
jacob blake okay yep you have uh you
have uh we'll go through floyd floyd was
i still don't think that
i think the coroner's report was
accurate it doesn't seem like he died
from the knee and the neck at all
especially someone who does grappling
though i don't think the police officer
should have done that that's improper
training still
that being said let's go through it uh
jacob blake dionne k who was the guy
with a little spit hood recently
michael brown if there is a single tamir
rice yeah trayvon martin if there's a
single instance of just some guy being
pulled over by an officer a black guy
going
officer i'm a concealed carry holder and
i would like you to know that
if that exists yeah show me in all these
scenarios
the most recent ones completely
justified entirely i make no apologies
entirely justified with jacob dionne
every single time this happens we all
sit down and go okay wait let's wait
let's wait let's see what happens
and then we get more contacts and every
single time at least the recent ones
they've all because that's what you're
supposed to do if you have any
journalistic integrity
or just these organizations you're
supposed to do that as a person and i
don't
i don't have your journalistic integrity
all i am
is a man now that means that there
should be some base level of integrity
which doesn't seem to really affect
others in the media
like chris chromos we'll get to in a
second and young young people are taking
cues from this so
if you put all of these people up as if
they're all heroes
then they are learning their morality
from that they're learning that well as
long as you have the right skin color
and you
you can act as you know as wildly as you
want and disrespectfully as you want
right you will be held up as a martyr
and then also hey let's go uh steal some
nikes
yeah right that's how you get a
generation of bad people go
burn down the cnn building right exactly
don lemon's like what i'm
what up well actually downloading sort
of middle of like i'm on your side and
brian stelster's like we're
hear it we're on your side right stop it
i'd like to be you step up
i won't have any sexual assault in my
office which is unlocked
i'm turning around
[Laughter]
oh my gosh well look if they're if they
really do want to save people we made
this point i think last week in one of
the shows if you want to save people
from being
shot by police the exact opposite of
what you're doing would work right now
you are creating the opportunity for
people to think they can do whatever
they want to do
with police officers the number one
there is a study that shows this it is
not color
it is not race it's not ethnicity it's
not sexuality it is behavior the number
one determining factor of how an
interaction
will go with the police officer is your
behavior if you don't fight the cops
if you don't try to punch them or pull a
gun or pull a knife or taser them in the
face
you'll probably be also unlikely to act
that way if you have a father in the
home
right that's the single biggest
statistical indicator that we have
before it reaches that point before it
reaches that fever pitch speaking of
sports analogies
hey chris cuomo and we're going to go
soon to exclusive uh at mug club because
this is going to be a fun segment
because i'm going to lay out a little
bit more with chris cuomo
really looking forward to our fight
though on no on october 30th
any man who enters the arena that being
said um
the lesser cuomo the lesser brother
cuomo here chris is a compulsive
liar and this shouldn't bother people
some people may say this is petty
this is petty and small-minded i agree
but it's chris cuomo so
the rules are different let's both get
in the mud uh he posted this to
instagram
uh trying to convince people
which is just here's the thing you know
i've always said you know how you're
disciplined
is if you stick with your plan if you do
what needs to be done
even when it's no longer exciting and no
one is watching here's how you know
you're a compulsive liar
you lie about things that nobody cares
about until you brought it up
and lied about it and then doubled down
like chris chromo trying to convince
everyone that he can alley-oop
double-handed dunk on a standard 10-foot
rim here you go
wow i want to keep the summoning for the
payload but it doesn't matter
we have okay all right we do have uh
coming up here behind that we're going
to get into this we have footage of
other comparably sized nba players at
six foot two dunking what it looks like
along with the doubling down in the ten
thousand dollar bet that chris cuomo put
out
for people who said there's no way
that's ten feet or there's no way that's
you if it is ten feet
this guy has made it his cause du jour
we're going to get into that behind uh
uh but for all mug club members here at
the
ladder with credit.com uh but before
that for people who are still watching
um keep in mind only on mug club uh
which is effectively like a new
pay-per-view
uh the fight between exhibition fight
between me and chris cuomo will be
october 3rd here's a preview
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
october 3rd we are going to continue
getting more into
dunk gate uh livecatter.com youtube we
love you people who watch for free we
still
love you being here even though you're
freeloaders but for right now youtube
you can piss off dude